[Music]
what does America mean to you
your removal is final there's nothing
you can do sorry but this is my home New
York is my home
13.8 billion years ago the Big Bang
created the Stars the planets the
galaxies compared to the life span of
the universe our lives begin and end in
a single day no Daniel Natasha what's
with the notebooks calls home what are
they about wait let me guess love not
all of them I don't believe in love so
no magic no fade no meant to be what if
I told you I could get you to fall in
love with me just give me a day an hour
when your key ingredients to fall in
love my ingredients our friendship
chemistry The X Factor what's the X
Factor don't worry we've got it this
isn't gonna make me change my mind mr.
plaid tie did you just call me Pat I'm
glad time my family is from Korea in
that Thailand that is not what I said so
you can stop waiting for an apology oh
I'm waiting for something but not for an
apology
[Music]
now I don't know
[Music]
but I think I could love oh my gosh yo
what are you so afraid of listen I
wasn't born here what my family is
leaving tomorrow this is real and I know
fill it to the choice we make
the path thought she was you don't have
forever
[Music]
all we have is a single day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you